Durante muchos años, décadas incluso, las
ricas socialdemocracias nórdicas fueron consideradas
como el refugio perfecto para la inmigración.
Sin que importara el origen, la raza, la religión,
ni ninguna otra condición, la mayoría de
estos países se construyeron con la llegada
de centenares de miles de extranjeros.
Sin embargo, desde hace algún tiempo, todo
esto ha empezado a cambiar. La política migratoria
ha sido, incluso, decisiva a la hora de promover
cambios de gobierno.
Por ejemplo, la mitad de los cuatro países
nórdicos continentales ya no están en manos
de partidos socialdemócratas.
Los gobiernos conservadores se han abierto
paso en Suecia y Finlandia.
Y en Dinamarca el gobierno está formado por
una gran coalición formada por socialdemócratas
y liberal-conservadores.
Claro que, en este último caso, quizás te
sorprenda, pero hablamos de un país que lleva
ya años siendo particularmente duro contra
la inmigración ilegal y muy restrictivo con
las políticas de refugiados, sin importar
realmente quién gobierne.
Fijaos.
(Mette Frederiksen, el rostro de la izquierda
antiinmigración en Dinamarca
Defensora de una política de "cero refugiados",
su gobierno ha llevado a cabo un controvertido
proyecto para reubicar a los solicitantes
de asilo en Ruanda mientras se procesan sus
solicitudes. El país también ha revocado
los permisos de residencia a sirios procedentes
de regiones que considera seguras. - France24)
Y claro, puede que en este punto muchos de
vosotros os estéis preguntando… ¿Por qué?
¿Por qué los países nórdicos, que tradicionalmente
han sido tan abiertos y tan tolerantes con
la llegada de migrantes, ahora están cambiando
radicalmente de tono?
Y lo que resulta aún más importante, ¿qué
tipo de políticas están poniendo en marcha
y por qué hablamos de ellas en VisualPolitik?
¿Acaso puede ser este el anticipo de lo que
está por venir en los próximos años?
Pues bien, estas y más preguntas os las vamos
a responder a continuación.
Gasolina y arranquemos/Expresión personalizada.
[Por cierto… Si os gusta lo que hacemos,
queréis recibir más contenido exclusivo
y ayudarnos a crecer, no olvidéis que podéis
echarnos una mano en el Patreon de VisualPolitik.
Recibiréis, boletines, contenido exclusivo,
merchandising también exclusivo y muchas
más cosas que estamos preparando.
Y, por supuesto, nos ayudarás a seguir creciendo.
Por ejemplo, la llegada de VisualEconomik
tuvo mucho pero que mucho que ver con vuestro
apoyo en Patreon. Os dejo el enlace en la
descripción. Muchísimas gracias a todos
los que nos ya nos apoyáis mes tras mes.
Y también cómo no, a todos los que estáis
al otro lado de la pantalla, vídeo tras vídeo.]
La primera pregunta que creo que tenemos que
responder es… ¿Por qué? ¿Por qué los
nórdicos cada vez son más reacios con el
tema de la inmigración? ¿Qué diantres ha
pasado para que se produzca semejante cambio?
Pues bien, lo cierto es que la respuesta es
compleja, y hay muchas variables involucradas.
Por ejemplo, la insuficiente capacidad de
integración de tantas personas de culturas
tan diferentes puede estar provocando, como
veremos, algunos problemas de seguridad.
Pero con mucha diferencia, lo que más ha
influido en este cambio de paradigma tiene
que ver con el Estado de Bienestar, sin duda
la columna vertebral del modelo de cohesión
social de estos países.
No es ningún secreto, en Suecia, Finlandia,
Noruega, Dinamarca e Islandia el Estado juega
un rol central en la protección de las personas.
Es con mucho la característica más conocida
de los países nórdicos.
Básicamente, si naces en uno de estos países,
es casi seguro que no tendrás problema para
acceder a la atención sanitaria, a un hogar,
a una pensión o a subsidios de todo tipo,
especialmente cuando hablamos de natalidad.
Este gráfico nos lo deja muy claro.
Para que os hagáis una idea, los cinco países
nórdicos están en el top 10 de los países
con más gasto sobre el PIB en educación
y sanidad. Y en el podium, encontramos dos,
Islandia y Dinamarca.
Lógicamente, estos elefantiásicos Estados
del Bienestar se tienen que financiar de alguna
forma: por ejemplo, vía impuestos.
Los países nórdicos tienen una presión
fiscal de más del 40%.
Y evidentemente, que sean economías históricamente
ricas, avanzadas y muy competitivas también
ayuda a tener unos servicios públicos de
primera.
Esto implica que, en estos países, un alto
porcentaje de los trabajadores son profesionales
altamente cualificados, con salarios elevados.
Algo que facilita que el Estado pueda recaudar
mucho y mantener altísimas prestaciones sociales
sin limitar excesivamente el poder adquisitivo
de sus trabajadores y la competitividad de
sus empresas.
Ahora bien, ¿cuál es el problema? Pues el
problema es que una parte muy grande de la
inmigración que han recibido estos países
en los últimos años son personas sin una
buena formación educativa ni profesional.
Y eso limita mucho su contribución fiscal,
al tiempo que, además, tienden a consumir
más recursos públicos.
La falta de cualificación, además, conlleva
serios problemas para acceder al mercado laboral,
pese a que hablamos de países con niveles
de desempleo muy reducido. Y, eso no es todo.
Dado que en estos países las prestaciones
sociales suelen ser muy altas, en ocasiones
provocan un efecto desplazamiento:
Digamos que puede llegar a ser más rentable
recibir subsidios que tener un empleo de baja
cualificación. El problema es que esto a
la larga provoca problemas de integración,
mucha más economía sumergida y, también,
el surgimiento de grupos criminales.
[Sobre esto último ya os hablamos en un pasado
vídeo sobre Suecia que, si estáis viendo
este vídeo, me da que también os va a interesar
y mucho. Os dejo el enlace en la descripción.]
El caso es que, por estos motivos, el gran
aumento de la inmigración que ha tenido lugar
en Europa en los últimos años, ha impactado
mucho más en los asistencialistas estados
nórdicos que en el resto.
Además, pensadlo un momento, el incentivo
de la gente para ir a países con tantos subsidios
es enorme. Lo que, lógicamente, ha conllevado
también un importante aumento del gasto “social”
en estos países.
Y, luego, si a todo esto le sumamos, además,
el incremento de refugiados registrado desde
el estallido de la guerra de Ucrania, el cóctel
se pone aún más amargo.
Queridos amigos, amigas, todo esto que os
estamos contando ha tenido dos efectos muy
claros:
Por un lado, los nórdicos están viendo cómo
sus servicios públicos y su estado de bienestar
se están degradando, básicamente porque
cada vez hay más demandantes. Deman dantes
que, en la mayoría de los casos, no han aportado
nada o muy poco al sistema. Lo que a corto
y medio plazo genera un importante gap estructural.
Y por otro, tenemos el efecto económico y
financiero, ya que algunos países han tenido
que optar o bien por recortar las prestaciones,
o bien por aumentar los impuestos.
(Noruega aumentará los impuestos en 3.000
millones de dólares a las empresas eléctricas
y piscifactorías
Los costes relacionados con la acogida de
refugiados, los proyectos de construcción
pública en curso, el pago de prestaciones
y los subsidios a la electricidad de los hogares
aumentarán en unos 100.000 millones de coronas
en 2023, según ha afirmado el gobierno. - Reuters)
Hablamos de un escenario que está empezando
a provocar mucho malestar.
Y precisamente para frenar esta deriva, las
viejas y conocidas socialdemocracias nórdicas
están endureciendo los requisitos para acceder
a las prestaciones públicas, al tiempo que
también están acabando con su política
de puertas abiertas y su tradicional tolerancia
con la inmigración.
(El nuevo gobierno de Finlandia anuncia un
"cambio de paradigma" con medidas enérgicas
contra la inmigración
Los permisos de residencia concedidos bajo
protección internacional "pasarán a ser
temporales y su duración se reducirá al
mínimo de la UE.” [...] En el futuro serán
"revocados si una persona está de vacaciones
en su país de origen". [...] También pretende
establecer sistemas separados de prestaciones
de seguridad social para inmigrantes y residentes
permanentes. - France24)
Ahora bien, si todo esto que os estamos contando
no os parece suficiente, esperad un momento,
porque no hemos hecho nada más que empezar.
(Los países nórdicos reforzarán la colaboración
en materia de deportaciones de inmigrantes
Un objetivo común era "garantizar la deportación
de extranjeros sin permiso de residencia"
a sus países de origen - Infomigrantes)
El 31 de octubre de 2023 los cinco países
nórdicos firmaron tres iniciativas que suponen
un paso más en este completo cambio de paradigma.
Hablamos de una nueva estrategia para promover
la salida voluntaria de inmigrantes y refugiados,
así como la expulsión de inmigrantes ilegales.
Ahora bien, incluso teniendo en cuenta este
cambio, lo cierto es que hay un país en concreto
que está siendo con mucha diferencia el más
duro a la hora de intentar atajar los problemas
que se han causado en las últimas décadas.
Un país en el que la mano dura es un consenso
general entre todas las fuerzas políticas
Hablamos… De Dinamarca.
Lo que os vamos a contar a continuación puede
que os sorprenda a muchos. Y sobre todo puede
que cambie un poco la opinión o la imagen
que tenéis del país del Lego y el regaliz.
Dinamarca hace apenas tres décadas era uno
de los países más abiertos a la inmigración
y a los refugiados de toda Europa y quizás
de todo el mundo. También era uno de los
que más ayudas ponía sobre la mesa. Sin
embargo, de esa Dinamarca ya no queda ni la
sombra.
Y claro, la pregunta es… ¿De qué hablamos
exactamente cuando decimos que Dinamarca usa
la mano dura? ¿Será acaso el alumno aventajado
que está marcando el camino de una nueva
política en toda Europa?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(O POR LAS BUENAS, O POR LAS MALAS)
Como ya os hemos dicho, Dinamarca es con diferencia
el país de los nórdicos que ha adoptado
un enfoque más radical en contra de la inmigración
ilegal. El país más duro de la región nórdica
y, quizás, de toda Europa.
Para empezar, esto no es algo estrictamente
nuevo.
No es una decisión que se tomase anteayer
precisamente. Y para prueba, tenemos los acuerdos
que Dinamarca firmó y, más importante aún,
los que no firmó, en el marco de la Unión
Europea.
Y es que, veréis, después de que los daneses
rechazasen en un primer referéndum el Tratado
de Maastricht, que es uno de los tratados
fundacionales de la Unión Europea, las autoridades
comunitarias acordaron con Copenhague cuatro
cláusulas de exclusión voluntaria.
De ellas, dos mantienen su validez y aplicación
real actualmente. Fijaos.
En primer lugar, los daneses no adoptarían
el Euro y se quedarían con la corona danesa,
lo cual, evidentemente, no es relevante para
el tema del que os estamos hablando.
Pero la segunda, en cambio, sí es mucho más
importante. Y es que Dinamarca también está
exenta de cumplir la mayor parte de las leyes
y obligaciones europeas en materia, entre
otros, de asilo y de reparto de refugiados
e inmigrantes irregulares.
Esto fue algo que se acordó en 1997, con
el Tratado de Ámsterdam, y desde entonces
lo cierto es que los daneses han hecho casi
lo que han querido con su política migratoria.
Ahora bien, ¿cuál es el mayor exponente
de todo esto? Pues ni más ni menos que su
política de cero refugiados.
Sí, lo habéis oído bien.
Hasta la guerra de Ucrania, Dinamarca apenas
aceptó refugiados y, a los que aceptó, como
es el caso de algunos sirios que huían de
la guerra, ahora los está empezando a invitar
a marcharse.
Incluso a varios cientos de ellos, directamente
los ha expulsado al considerar que sus regiones
de origen ya son zonas seguras.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en términos
per cápita, por cada refugiado que llega
a Dinamarca llegan 6 a Alemania y a Suecia.
En 2021, antes de la guerra de Ucrania, solo
había 36.000 refugiados en el país, y en
2020 el país registró el menor número de
solicitudes de asilo en 20 años: poco más
de 1.500.
Evidentemente, esto responde a algo, y ese
algo es una política muy hostil hacia este
tipo de migraciones.
Para empezar, en 2016, el gobierno danés
aprobó una ley popularmente conocida como
“Ley de Joyería”.
Una polémica ley que fue aprobada por una
amplia mayoría del parlamento, 81 de 109
de los diputados presentes, incluido el Partido
Socialdemócrata, que ya en ese momento estaba
liderado por la actual primera ministra, Mette
Frederiksen.
Ahora bien, ¿en qué consiste esta ley? Pues
agarraos a la silla.
Resumiendo mucho, la llamada Ley de Joyería
obliga a los solicitantes de asilo recién
llegados al país a que entreguen al Estado
danés sus objetos de valor como una forma
de pagar su estancia, incluidas joyas y oro,
a excepción, de alguna pieza limitada que
pueda tener un particular valor sentimental.
La ley también establece que los refugiados
que lleguen al país con más de 10.000 coronas,
algo menos de 1.500 dólares, tienen que contribuir
con los costes de su alojamiento.
Y además, la ley también dificulta y mucho
las reuniones familiares. Los solicitantes
de asilo tienen que esperar al menos tres
años para poder solicitar poder llevar a
sus familias a Dinamarca.
Todo esto, obviamente, tiene como objetivo
desincentivar que los refugiados elijan Dinamarca
como opción, ya que hay muchas otras opciones
en Europa con mejores condiciones de acogida.
Y lo cierto es que en este sentido la ley,
con las cifras en la mano, está funcionando.
Para muchos esta ley es inhumana y racista,
sobre todo teniendo en cuenta que el gobierno
danés - oh, sorpresa - no aplicó nada de
eso a los refugiados ucranianos que llegaron
huyendo de la guerra.
Para otros, sin embargo, es una herramienta
clave para evitar la formación de ghettos
y de sociedades paralelas, que es el motivo
fundamental con el que los políticos tanto
de izquierdas como de derechas la justifican.
Pero es que aún hay más, mucho más.
Por ejemplo, cuando un inmigrante o refugiado
recibe una orden de expulsión del país y
no coopera con las autoridades, en Dinamarca
se le interna en un centro de retorno donde
está obligado a residir y pernoctar cada
noche.
[Supongo que llamarles centros de expulsión
quedaba menos estético…]
Pues bien, el país cuenta con al menos tres
centros de retorno para extranjeros en los
que, en algunos casos, algunos extranjeros
pasan largas temporadas.
Es una espera con un destino incierto. Y ojo,
no estamos hablando de centros de internamiento
temporal de inmigrantes ilegales recién llegados,
como los que podemos encontrar en muchos países.
Hablamos de extranjeros que ya estaban en
Dinamarca pero que, por cualquier motivo,
se les ha ordenado la expulsión.
Además, en estos centros se les aplica un
régimen de conducta, disciplina y normas
muy estrictas. También hay un régimen de
castigos en caso de incumplimiento que prevé
multas e incluso prisión.
Pero, con todo, si hay una medida polémica
y radical entre todas las que os hemos contado
y os vamos a contar, es la que Dinamarca ha
tomado en contra de los ghettos de extranjeros.
O como les gusta más llamarlo: “las sociedades
paralelas”.
Y es que, veréis tal y como ya os contamos
en el vídeo que hicimos sobre Suecia, uno
de los problemas que dificulta la integración
de muchos inmigrantes es su concentración
en zonas donde apenas tienen contacto con
la sociedad local.
Hablamos de zonas, barrios, normalmente, llenos
de viviendas públicas que se le entregaron
a estos inmigrantes por considerarlos colectivos
vulnerables.
Zonas en las que se terminan creando comunidades
cerradas, con su propia cultura, costumbres
y a veces de facto incluso leyes. Hablamos
de espacios donde en muchos casos el contacto
de sus vecinos con la población local de
los países de acogida es nulo.
Incluso también hablamos de lugares donde
buena parte de la población residente extranjera
no tiene empleos regulares, o termina dedicándose
a actividades delictivas. Y claro, la exclusión
conduce a más exclusión, y eso nunca termina
en nada bueno.
En este sentido, estas zonas son las que han
servido como caldo de cultivo para el crimen
organizado en países como Suecia, donde están
experimentando un inédito problema de seguridad
que está superando a las propias autoridades.
Pues bien, Dinamarca es el país europeo y,
puede que del mundo incluso, que más duramente
le ha declarado la guerra a estas zonas “guetificadas”,
a estas “sociedades paralelas”.
Por ejemplo, en 2018 Dinamarca aprobó una
polémica ley cuya mayor iniciativa consiste
en reorganizar y rediseñar barrios pobres
de vivienda pública que tengan una alta concentración
de inmigrantes no occidentales con un plazo
límite: 2030.
Un plan que fue anunciado por un gobierno
conservador, pero que ha sido puesto en marcha
por el gobierno socialdemócrata de Frederiksen.
Ahora bien, ¿en qué consiste esa reorganización?
Pues básicamente en entrar e n esos barrios
para hacerse con las casas. En algunos, casos,
incluso, entrar con bulldozers para demoler
viviendas públicas.
Sí, sí, lo habéis oído bien.
Previamente, el gobierno danés lleva a cabo
el realojo forzoso de sus vecinos que, en
algunos casos, como os podéis imaginar, se
resisten a irse de sus casas.
(Dinamarca envía la bola de demolición a
los barrios “no occidentales”
Un programa gubernamental está utilizando
las demoliciones y los realojos para rehacer
barrios con inmigrantes, pobreza o crimen.
- The New York Times)
En concreto, la ley exige que en los barrios
en los que al menos la mitad de la población
sea de origen o ascendencia no occidental
la proporción de viviendas públicas no puede
superar el 40 % del total.
Para declarar una zona como susceptible de
actuación, la ley indica que se tienen que
dar al menos dos de las siguientes características:
Bajos ingresos, malos resultados educativos,
alto desempleo o alto porcentaje de habitantes
con condenas penales.
Uno de los lugares que sirve como ejemplo
de ghetto es el barrio
donde el 43% de sus residentes están desempleados,
el 82% tiene origen no occidental, el 53%
tiene escasa educación y el 51% tiene ingresos
bajos.
En la práctica, esto significa que de aquí
a 2030 el gobierno danés tendrá que derribar
o, en su defecto, vaciar y revender a otras
personas, más de 4.000 viviendas públicas
en barrios como ese. A día de hoy, alrededor
de medio millar ya han sido demolidas.
Muchas de las que no son demolidas y se decide
conservarlas se venden a inversores que las
rehabilitan y luego las venden a precio de
mercado a nuevos habitantes de mayor poder
adquisitivo.
En la práctica, la idea es relocalizar y
diluir a la población inmigrante dentro de
la sociedad danesa, evitando que los extranjeros
se concentren en zonas concretas, se aíslen
del resto de la sociedad y, por tanto, no
se integren.
Conceptualmente, la idea no es mala, lo que
sí es más controvertido es el enfoque forzoso
y obligatorio que se le ha dado en Dinamarca.
(“Adoptamos el punto de vista básico de
que concentrar los problemas sociales aumenta
los problemas sociales. [...] No creemos que
sea bueno crecer en un vecindario donde hay
muchos problemas sociales y relacionados con
la integración.” - Kaare Dybvad, actual
ministro socialdemócrata de Inmigración
e Integración)
Me imagino que aquí habrá opiniones para
todos los gustos.
Pero aún no hemos terminado, aún hay más.
Aparte de esta política de vivienda y realojo,
Dinamarca también obliga a que los niños
pequeños de estas zonas pasen al menos 25
horas semanales en centros preescolares donde
se les enseña el idioma danés y, cito literalmente,
los “valores daneses”.
Y aunque todavía es pronto para saber si
estas medidas funcionarán o fracasarán,
lo que sí sabemos es que Dinamarca se está
convirtiendo en una especie de laboratorio
para muchos países europeos con problemas
similares.
Claro que uno de los riesgos que existen,
y no es un riesgo precisamente menor, es que
la política de realojos forzosos y de mano
dura contra los refugiados y la inmigración
ilegal aumente el sentimiento de desarraigo.
Cuando una persona se siente muy desarraigada,
señalada y estigmatizada por la sociedad
que le rodea, puede, en algunos casos, desarrollar
una rabia y un odio que puede dar lugar a
mayores niveles de radicalización y comportamientos
fuera de la ley.
Obviamente, esto es algo que las autoridades
danesas saben, y que tendrán que vigilar.
Es un riesgo potencialmente muy importante
que hay que tener en cuenta.
El caso, amigos, es que en Dinamarca, a día
de hoy, el concepto “multiculturalismo”
genera un rechazo social importante.
(“En Dinamarca “multiculturalismo” es
realmente una palabra negativa.” - Tina
Gudrun Jensen, antropóloga en la Universidad
de Malmo.)
En otras palabras, que en la tierra de la
sirenita, ser un forastero que no ha sido
invitado podría conducirte de cabeza a tener
que nadar en aguas más turbulentas."
Y ojo, porque, lo que os hemos contado del
país nórdico anti-inmigración por excelencia
no es más que lo que podría estar a punto
de empezar a suceder en otros como Suecia
o Finlandia, cuyos gobiernos recientemente
han girado a la derecha.
La pregunta, llegados hasta aquí, es… ¿Funcionarán
todos estos planes?
Por ahora el debate os lo dejamos servido
a todos vosotros, así que dejadnos vuestra
opinión por aquí abajo en los comentarios.
Y muy importante, si os ha gustado este vídeo
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
nuestro canal para no perderos ninguna novedad.
También os recordamos que tenemos un Patreon
a través del cual podéis ayudarnos a seguir
creciendo y mejorando, a cambio de contenidos,
ventajas y regalos exclusivos. Os dejamos
el link en la descripción.
Una vez más, gracias por estar ahí. Un saludo
y hasta la próxima.